>> John Haskell:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to The Kluge Center
here at The Library of Congress.
The Kluge Center is right
through those doors over here,
where we have at The Kluge
Center scholars in residence
at both the postdoctoral level,
as well as more established
scholars, such as Ivan Krastev
who is our Chairman of
the panel here today.
I'm John Haskell, the
Director of The Kluge Center.
This panel is part of
a series that we do
that we call Conversations
on the State of Democracy,
and we're very glad you're here.
Avail yourself of the sodas
and the water and snacks,
and I think we're in for
a very interesting panel.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about how Ivan fits in here.
As you can see from
our materials,
he's the Kissinger Chair
in International Relations
and Foreign Policy here
at The Kluge Center.
He is the seventeenth
holder of that position.
The Kissinger Program
was originated by friends
of Henry Kissinger back at the
beginning of The Kluge Center
in 2000 and they endowed a
Chair for which we are grateful.
If you don't have a sense,
I know many of you are here
because you do have a
sense of Mr. Krastev
and the other panelists,
but I want to make it clear
that whenever I talk
about the fact
that The Kluge Center has
Ivan here for a couple
of months this year and a couple
more months next year people
are impressed.
He is known as perhaps
the authority on populism
and liberal democracy in Europe
and Russia, so he's here,
he's set-up this panel,
and I'm just going
to tell you a little
bit more about him.
He is the Chairman of the Center
for Liberal Studies in Sofia,
Bulgaria and the permanent
Fellow of the Institute
for Human Sciences, IWM, Vienna.
Ivan is going to lead a
conversation with the panelists
and then there'll
be an opportunity
for questions from you.
Take it away.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Thank you very much.
One of the most beautiful things
that Kissinger has ever said
is he said when people say
that they don't need
introduction don't do this
to them because they
take part in these things
for the pleasure of
being introduced.
So, of course, I'm not
as kind of spectacular
as this introduction was, but
it was a really great privilege
to be here and only somebody
who has not been part
of The Kluge Center doesn't
know how beautiful it is.
The people that you see on the
panel and some of the people
that you see in the room are
part of a strange project
that we started two
or three years ago,
and I'm basically going
to introduce it in order
to understand why we're
here and what we are doing.
There is a famous story
saying that the actor,
the Hollywood kind of megastar,
Cary Grant, once was invited
to a charity cocktail
in Hollywood,
but he has forgotten
his invitation.
And there was this very
tough lady on the entrance,
and he said I should enter,
where is your invitation?
He said, sorry, I
have forgotten it,
and she said, you cannot enter.
And he said, but
I am Cary Grant.
And she looked at him and said,
you don't look like Cary Grant.
And he said, nobody
looks like Cary Grant.
Ah. And this is quite important
because when we started one
of the things that we can
be very much interested
in was there was all this
talk about liberal order.
The liberal order never looked
in the way basically this
course can be writing about it.
Nobody looks like Cary Grant.
But at the same time some years
ago when basically all the talk
about the crisis of liberal
order started we figured
out that this course on
the hypocrisy of the West
on the wild side, but
also the Western discourse
on the hypocrisy of
others is becoming the very
central discourse.
And what is quite important
is that attacking somebody
for being hypocritical is
the way basically to attack
without offering an alternative.
You are attacking all the
time people for standing
up to their own ideals or values
so you don't need basically
to do anything else.
So then the Center for Liberal
Strategy was a great support
from the Robert Bush
Foundation, we decided to do one
of those projects that
people are not doing anymore.
To connect the very
interesting group of people,
a mixture of policymakers,
policy intellectuals, academics,
and we decided to visit four
countries in which the discourse
of hypocrisy is central
to the way they comment
on foreign policy.
Russia, basically
very much talking
about the power revolutions
and to the native expansion.
Turkey, very much
centering on the relations
with the European Union.
Iran, because of
the nuclear deal.
And also being interested
in Greece
because during the European
crisis there was a lot of talk
about the bailout plan and was
basically Brussels hypocritical
in the way it was
treating these countries.
On the other side, the West
itself was very much kind
of unhappy with the hypocrisies
of the regimes which likes
to talk like democracies,
so liberal order
but at the same time
the deal was
that they had been
faking it all the time.
So what we have been doing is
was a lot of serious meetings,
but I'm talking about
meetings, 30, 40 people,
and trying to cover the
whole political spectrum,
members of government, both
Russia, Turkey around members
of the opposition,
academic think tanks.
And then we came here
because interestingly enough,
nevertheless that people
basically can be very critical
to what is happening
in the US when it comes
to foreign policy
there is one thing
that the current administration
cannot be accused of
and this is being hypocritical.
In a certain way you
have a very strong talk
about interests only, most of
the policies are not justified
on a value level, and for
us the question was how much
words matter.
And our starting assumption is
that policy is not simply
what governments do,
but also how they
justify their policies.
And even one and the same
act of the government,
being justified differently
is a different policy.
And this for us was a trite
way basically to make sense
of the transformation
of the world.
So what we are going
to do, we're not going
to present what is
interesting about this project,
we're going to end
up with a report
with much more interesting was
to keep the diversity of views.
When we talk about the crisis
of liberal order we are going
to present four different
points of view based
on the four different
types of a crisis.
In a certain way everybody
talks about the crisis
of liberal order on
institutional level,
value levels, but for every
person this is also the crisis
of certain contacts
that you know best.
So I'm going to start
with Robert Cooper,
which is probably one
of the most legendary
European diplomats and author,
he wrote one of the classical
books of the self-understanding
of the way the European Union
was working throughout the
banking of nations.
He has been the Foreign
Policy Advisor to Tommy Blair
and that he left because he was
not supporting the war in Iraq
and he was the Foreign
Policy Advisor
to Javier Salona [assumed
spelling] and then
to Crattie Ashton
[assumed spelling].
And from this point of view he
and his view of BREXIT is going
to be the first thing
of the way we are trying
to introduce how
there is the kind
of a local crisis we are
experiencing, what is changing.
Robert?
>> Robert Cooper: Right.
Thank you.
So I'm going to say a few words
about where BREXIT came from,
about the referendum campaign
and about the consequence
of the UK leaving
the European Union
for the International Order.
First of all, where
did it come from?
Well, I'd be quite honest
because I'm not paid
by anybody so I say what I like.
It came from the
Conservative Party.
Conservative Party had a
problem, it had a problem
for a long time with
the European Union,
and it became quite serious for
David Cameron [assumed spelling]
and he decided to go above the
Party by having a referendum.
Actually, Harold Wilson did the
same thing back in the 1970s
with a different result.
And so the Conservative
Party is a kind
of institution in
long-term decline.
It used to have three
million members
and now it's somewhere
below 100,000,
so it's actually a increasingly
pathetic organization,
but it's one of the two
increasingly pathetic
organizations that runs
our country in Britain.
And David Cameron used
to go around saying,
the people of Britain are
demanding a say on Europe.
Actually, the people of
Britain didn't care that much,
they were interested in
education, in housing,
they were wondering why their
salaries would remain static
whereas those of the bankers
who had ruined the
country were racing ahead.
They were wondering about
all those normal things,
they weren't that problemed with
the European Union, however,
they then held the
referendum campaign
and everybody became bothered
with it and have never ceased
to be bothered with
it ever since.
It's the way in which you may
be friends when you start a war
with a country, but by the
end of the war it's guaranteed
that you've got enemies.
And so the referendum
created the problem,
it didn't solve the problem
for the Conservative Party,
but it transferred the
problem to a higher level.
And instead of ruining the
Conservative Party they decided
to ruin the whole country.
That's the kind of
proximate cause
of the referendum
was the problem
in the Conservative Party.
The longer run cause
was a general failure
of the government and
all responsible people
to explain the European
Union properly.
Now it's very difficult, it
has become increasingly visible
because this is a very
complicated gigantic
in a way enterprise
and institution,
and actually what's
happening now it makes clear
that almost nobody
understands it completely.
I worked there for 10 years and
I discover new things every day
that I didn't know about it.
About like, for example,
that if Britain leaves
without an agreement
the airports will close
because no planes will have air
worthiness because they come
from the European Union.
Thousands of things
like that will stop.
It's a sort of, it's hidden,
but it's much more important
than anyone understands.
So it was out of the
Conservative Party's problem
and general ignorance.
And then the referendum campaign
made extraordinarily good use
of the ignorance, indeed,
it used the ignorance
by telling an enormous amount
of people wanted to leave,
telling an enormous
amount of lies.
Very direct, visible,
traceable lies,
but they got away with them.
Even government ministers
demonstrated
that they didn't know
about the European Union,
and people didn't know sort
of as usual there was
an immigration element,
what role is foreigner,
particularly what role is
European foreigners doing here?
And people thought
several things
about the European immigrants,
and Britain is full of them,
this makes London
much more colorful.
They thought that these people
were responsible for the decline
in the social services
because they were arriving
and making use of
the social services,
which they hadn't paid for.
It's not true, actually the
immigrants were mostly young
people, they were healthy,
they didn't use the
healthcare system,
they were not contributors
to the social services,
so that wasn't true.
Another bit of ignorance,
you ask people in Britain
where does foreign investment
come from in Britain?
And they'll tell you, well,
about they say I think,
they normally guess that
about 30% comes from the EU,
that's a mistake, it's
actually 63% comes from the EU.
They think about 30%
probably comes from the USA,
that's wrong, it's actually 17%.
They think that --
no, sorry, it's 23% --
they think that 17% comes from
China, the answer is it's less
than 1% comes from China.
Overwhelmingly investment in
Britain that's foreign comes
from the EU, and that
means that supply chains go
across national boundaries,
having no customs controls
and things like that, having
completely open market
for the EU is absolutely
essential
for the British economy.
So the campaign was
full of lies.
And the campaign also took
place at a rather unlucky moment
because of complaints
about immigration,
which were mostly not
justified, but this took place
at the moment when there was
a vast migration crisis going
on in the eastern Mediterranean
as a consequence
of the Syrian war.
Migration crisis was nowhere
near Europe, but it was all
over the TV screens, so that
was another bit of bad luck.
And then there was a bit
of sloppiness on the part
of the government in the way
in which the referendum
was organized,
but I leave that aside.
Now what about the
consequences of BREXIT?
Assuming if it's going to
happen, I assume that it's going
to happen, although I'm
not absolutely certain
because I had never seen
such chaos in Britain before.
Anything is possible at the
moment, but the likely result is
that the UK leaves, that will
leave the UK isolated, weakened,
impoverished, but actually
is bad for the liberal order
because the UK is
a liberal country
and it's played a useful
role in what I think
of as the liberal order,
which is essentially NATO
and the European Union
and then you've got one
or two slightly less
important add-ons, like the IMF
and the WPO and the UN, which
doesn't function that well,
but basically the West
is the liberal order.
And the UK isolated, angry,
quarreling with its
neighbors is not a good thing
for liberal order.
And then a final remark on
what is the liberal order?
I think another definition
for the liberal order is
it's what's brought us peace
for 70 years in all
kinds of different forms.
NATO, and when I think of NATO
bringing peace I'm thinking
of the cold war, but not just of
the cold war, peace between East
and West, I'm thinking
of peace within Europe.
The fact that before NATO
every country in Europe looked
at their military and
compared it with the military
of their neighbor,
and Britain used
to run something called
the two Navy standard.
We wanted to have a
Navy that was equal
to the next two countries.
Sometime the end of the 19th
Century we stopped counting the
USA because we knew
we couldn't compete,
but so everybody compared
themselves to their neighbors.
Under NATO nobody does
that unless they complain
about the Germans not
spending enough on defense.
So NATO is a powerful part
of what has brought peace
for 70 years and
the European Union.
There are two ways of
making, of having peace.
One is to be very powerful,
balance of power to the left.
The other is to have
good political relations
with your neighbors.
And the European
Union is intended
and systematically does that.
Now people will tell
you today, well, peace,
who cares, that's all old hat.
Now I was sort of
brought up with Joan Baez,
so I take this more seriously,
but actually what people
in Britain forget is that we had
a low intensity war which went
on for 20 years or
more in Ireland
and we do have a land border.
We think we're an island, but
we don't, we have a land border
with the Republic of Ireland.
And a condition of
the peace settlement
in Ireland is called the Good
Friday Agreement by most of us
and in Northern Ireland
called the Belfast Agreement,
always a bad sign that when
they have different names
for the same thing.
But the background condition
of that was membership
of the European Union, that
you didn't need to have,
on the one hand that you didn't
need to have a border in Ireland
so that those who
wished to could live
in the united Ireland as,
indeed, in morph if you wished
to you could have a
Republic of Ireland passport,
but that's very important.
And I can develop
a scenario in which
if you recreate the border you
can recreate what they called
the troubles, but which was
actually a low intensity war.
It's perfectly possible.
the second way in which the
European Union helped end the
war in Ireland was it put Dublin
and London for the first time
in a community together where
they cooperated and dealt
with each other not as
a former colonial power,
the former colonial
victim, but as equals
and that was also
essential in the Irish peace.
So when people tell you the
European Union is a peace
project it's not nonsense, and
the weird thing is that Britain,
which is a primary beneficiary
of this, hasn't noticed it
until now, they still
don't understand it.
They, I refer to my fellow
countrymen, I should say.
so that's, I'm sorry,
there's much more to say
and I've gone too far.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Thank you very much.
I was listening, and if I
remember rightly during the 20th
Century there is only one year
in which a British soldier
has not been killed in a small
or a big war outside of the
territory of the United Kingdom.
And, by the way,
this year is 1968.
But from Britain we are going
to move to the United States.
And for most of us coming here
and we had a lot of meetings
for the last three days,
the biggest problem is you
have two kinds of schools
of thoughts in Europe today.
There are people who are seeing
the changes in the United States
as kind of a car accident,
something happened,
there was a major kind
of accident in 2016,
but they are going to
return back to the normal
so we should wait for four,
eight, I don't know, 12 years
and then basically everything
is going to be the way it was.
And there was a people who
said, and I'm much closer
to this school, is that the
current President didn't create
the wave, he's surfing on it.
There was a major
transformation,
there was a certain type of
a foreign policy consensus
that did not fit to the
public consensus there,
there are certain changes
that are going to survive,
nevertheless, of who is
going to come to power.
And from this point
of view for us one
of the most interesting
questions was what are these
changes, what are the
emerging consensuses
of the way the United States now
views the world, keeping close
with the fact that
it's not simply
about American foreign
policy but also
about very much polarized
domestic political space.
And now I'll go to Rosa
Brooks here basically
to give her take
and how she sees it.
>> Rosa Brooks: Goodness,
that's a tough task,
explaining American
politics and foreign policy.
So, as Ivan said, this project
is about hypocrisy and the role,
negative and maybe
positive, that hypocrisy plays
in the discourse about the
liberal international order.
And maybe I should
just start by saying
that not only is Donald
Trump not a hypocrite,
he may be many things, right, he
may be lying, he may be corrupt,
he may care only about his own
interests, but partly for all
of those reasons it's hard
to call him a hypocrite.
He doesn't pretend to be
anything other than what he is.
I think the American people
and American policymakers are
also really hypocritical insofar
as hypocrisy implies, charges
of hypocrisy imply a level
of self-awareness and a
willingness to blink your eye
at contradictions and
self-serving behavior.
I think that the flaw in
American foreign policy and,
indeed, American
internal politics is
that we are entirely capable
of fully believing multiple
contradictory things at once
and we tend to truly believe
all the contradictory things.
I think that when it comes
to both the liberal
international order, itself,
and when it comes to
Americans' understandings
of our own country and our own
politics there are these central
contradictions in it that
we have never resolved
and we have lived for 70
plus years telling ourselves
that perhaps we don't have
to resolve them and trying
to pretend that they
don't exist.
And here's what they
are, let me start
with the so-called liberal
international order, right?
Think about the contradictions
that are at the heart
of the UN charter system that
emerges after World War II.
We have on the one
hand a profound
and quite revolutionary
commitment to the idea
of universal rights, universal
rights possessed by individuals,
not by virtue of their belonging
to a particular state or group,
but simply by virtue
of being human.
And from that notion of
individual human rights,
universal human rights that
everyone possesses simply
because they're human we get the
notion of self-determination,
which is of course an extension
of the deeply American
commitment
to democratic governance,
that individuals,
that governments have
legitimacy only insofar
as they rest upon the
consent of the individuals
that they are governing.
So we have this commitment
to individual rights,
which leads us to commitment to
self-determination and arguably
to democratic forms
of governance and
yet at the same time of
course the UN charter, itself,
enshrines a commitment to
maintaining the status quo,
the post-World War II status
quo in all kinds of ways,
including maintaining the
states that emerge out of that,
maintaining the power
structure that emerges
out of World War II,
specifically looking
at the permanent members
of the UN Security Council
with their veto power and
so forth, and a commitment
to non-interference,
to non-intervention
that says states do not
get to and are prohibited
from intervening in the
internal affairs of one another.
So that's, and the trouble is
of course those two things don't
actually fit very well together.
If you posit that
individuals have rights
to self-determination and to
free expression and to all sorts
of other things and
you posit that states
and international organizations,
such as the United Nations,
have a responsibility to
protect and defend the rights
of individuals and the
aspirations of peoples,
and then you also say, oh, but
by the way you can't interfere
in the status quo and by
the way a system which says
that five states have
permanent veto power
in the Security Council not
because a democracy
chose those states,
not because they have the
majority of the people,
but simply because,
because, just because.
You can't sustain that,
there's no possible way
to square those things
completely, and so you have
to either pretend the
contradiction doesn't exist,
or in contrast to
hypocrisy I think, as I said,
the American failing
is to manage
to maintain a very high
level of cognitive dissonance
in which you just have
two separate little boxes
in your head.
You have one box that says
commitment to individual rights
and self-determination and
democracy, and another box
that is a much more realist
kind of box, you know,
in international relations terms
that box says leave well
enough alone, power matters,
historical structure matters,
sorry stability trumps
individual rights
and universalist aspirations
all the time and you have
to keep those in
two separate boxes.
And so when you're talking
about one you mean it,
and when you're talking
about the other you mean it,
and if you're American you
keep those boxes so separate
that you don't actually have
to be confronted
with the difference.
If you're not American you're
far more inclined to say, hey,
wait a second, you know, hold
on, how can you believe both
of those things at once?
To which the answer is that
again unless you're very good
at cognitive dissonance you
can't, and I think the roots
that tension gives rise around
the globe to a tremendous amount
of anger, to charges
of hypocrisy and so on.
When it comes to
American internal politics
in many ways we remain a country
that ourselves are sort of torn
between those two impulses,
the impulse towards saying
every individual matters,
it's individual rights that
matter, and the impulse to say,
no, it's power and
concentrations of power
that matter more and
stability matters more.
And I think that in some ways
when we look at the election
of 2016, when we
look at what's going
on in the US right now we're
very much seeing a conflict
between a vision of
America that is very much
about the protection of rights
and universalist principles
versus a discourse that says,
nope, nope, it's about power,
it's about stability, it's about
protecting the prerogatives
of those who either hold power
and want to keep it or used
to hold power, have
recently lost it
and would like to have it back.
And I do think that a lot of
the support for the election
of President Trump has come
from that sort of second,
that latter group, who are
saying it's about power
and who keeps it
and whether those
who lost it recently
can get it back again.
There, too, you know I
don't think it's so much
about hypocrisy, but it's
about these competing visions
which most of us would
deny that we have,
and we deny that we have them,
we deny that they're competing.
But I do think that they --
I'm not terribly
optimistic I should say
about either the US politics --
Ivan, you asked whether will
we revert to normal here
in the United States, will
this moment be a blip, you know
and in two years or in six years
we say, oh, well, that was kind
of strange but that's over
now, we go back to usual both
in the United States and
in terms of the UK figures
out the whole BREXIT thing,
we all revert to normal?
I doubt it, I think
it's not impossible
that that could happen,
that everyone could just agree
let's just delete the last four
years, six years, eight years,
whatever it will
have been by then.
I think unfortunately somewhat
more likely, not inevitable
but more likely is that both
the international liberal order
and the American, the
particularly American experiment
in late empire democracy
both essentially crumble due
to their own internal
contradictions.
What comes after if
the American experiment
in the liberal international
order crumble?
I don't think it's
anything very good, right?
I don't see anybody kind of
waiting in the wings saying,
hey, we've got the
next great idea.
I think that we are probably
due, unfortunately both
in this country and globally,
for one of those periods
that could last three or four
years and could last decades
or even centuries of back to
power politics, back to power
and force as primary means
of resolving disputes,
and it's not going to be,
it's not an era I feel good
about leaving to my children
and my grandchildren,
but that's I think the direction
in which we're heading.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Thank you very much.
And, of course, Rosa
knows something
about this contradiction
because she's a famous,
also humorized professor,
who served in the Pentagon,
so she knows both worlds.
But one of the things which for
us was quite interesting was
that people automatically
believed that the return
to great power politics
is a return to realism,
and this is something that
I'm personally questioning
and this is what
not you're seeing.
This is in a way identity type
of a great power politics.
And Steven Walt [assumed
spelling],
one of the famous realists,
was part of the group.
It is one thing with this type
of a highly politicized and kind
of changing the way
nation interest is defined.
This very rational realism
view of foreign policy
in such a way it does
not look very convincing.
But Thomas Baggett
[assumed spelling],
who is the Foreign Policy
Advisor to the German President
and who is probably one of the
best known public intellectuals
in Germany when it
comes to foreign policy,
recently he said the end of
history was an American idea,
but European reality and
particularly German reality.
And I'm going to say why
for Europeans this talk
about the change of
language appeared
to be much more important
than to anybody else.
For the United States,
for Russia, for China,
for Turkey moving for a much
more liberal values colored
justification of
government acts.
It is a problem of choice.
European Union cannot
easily shift
to the national interest type of
justification of its policies.
It's not a nation state.
And, by the way, if you
see the nation states some
of these nation states
are very small.
I can easily understand
what it means for China
or for the United States
becoming protection is
nationalistic, but
you try to explain
to me how Bulgaria is going
to benefit from the world
in which everybody
goes this way.
And from this point of view in
a certain way the German dilemma
and the problem that Germany is
facing as a leading member state
in my view is one of the most
interesting, but also one
of the most challenging.
So, Thomas?
>> Thomas Bagger: Yes, thank
you, Ivan, and thank you
to all of you for coming.
I think, you know, when I
look back at the last 25,
30 years since the end of
the fall of, since the fall
of the wall, the end of the
cold war, which happened sort
of at half point in my life,
this was the most surprising,
the most unthinkable event
that I could possibly remember.
And I was in a US university
computer lab in College Park,
not very far from here, and
did my Masters Degree there
and this was sort of
before laptop time.
So we sat at this computer lab
and there were American students
coming in and they're saying,
telling and sort of saying
they're taking the wall down,
they're taking the wall down.
And I thought they must
have gotten something wrong,
which wall are they
talking about?
Because even with all
the runup to November 9,
1989 it was out of my
imagination as a 24 year old
that this could actually
happen and be true.
So it was, really it was
basically unthinkable.
I had grown-up with
it, it was impossible.
The most disruptive event that
I can think of in my lifetime.
But when I think back
over these last 30 years
and what has happened
since it struck me
that from this most
nonlinear event
that you can imagine most
Germans have derived a
thoroughly linear expectation
of what was to follow,
and I don't think
there's another country
where Francis Fukuyama's
thesis of the end of history
after 1989 was as
popular as in Germany
because it somehow fit
our own expectations
and our hopes in many ways.
You know, after having been on
the wrong side of history twice
in the 20th Century the
country finally found itself
on the right side of
history of stable democracy,
a market economy, and to say
that this is actually the
final destination of history
and now everybody else
would have to change
and essentially become like
us, but we had already arrived
at the destination, was
very appealing as a thought.
And so I think this assumption
of a grand convergence
that would happen, first with
the transformation of central
and eastern Europe,
then with a wave
of democratization elsewhere,
but eventually everywhere,
that was actually, that
was good and we would be
at the center of it again.
I think also that for a country
that had been burned so badly
by sort of charismatic idea
of leadership the notion
that personal agency didn't
really matter that much
because it, you know leaders
would basically just administer
the inevitable on a broader
flow of history that would lead
in a predetermined
direction, also had something
that was deeply appealing to
Germans much more so than,
I don't know, French
or Americans or others.
And, finally, what happened
since where I grew-up
in West Germany, we were
sort of a frontline state
in the cold war, highly
militarized, including lots
of American troops,
nuclear weapons and the same
on the other side
from the Soviets,
with all of that disappearing
in the 1990s and the notion
that for the first time
in Germany's history the country
was surrounded only by friends,
it basically drove threat
perception down to zero.
If we wouldn't meddle in other
people's affairs nobody would
meddle in ours,
and so essentially what was
left was a trading state, right?
So the limitations that had
been imposed in Germany one way
or another after World War II
suddenly seemed to transform us
into an avant-garde of history,
we were at the front of it
and if we considered
the European Union
to be the avant-garde
of integration globally
Germany was seen
as the avant-garde
within Europe.
And I think, you know this is
sort of somewhat simplified
and not everybody shared that,
but I think it was a
pretty broad sentiment,
including in the foreign policy,
security policy community.
And it took us awhile because
in a way what this view
of the international order
did, of which we were a product
as the Federal Republic of
Germany created in 1949,
what it did was it took our
own peculiar German history
and allowed us to
universalize it.
We took our own lessons
from history,
never again the holocaust
and, therefore, a strong focus
on human rights,
moving away from power,
moving towards what you
could call a judicialization
of international politics.
So you move away from power
to sort of rule of law system,
also in the international order,
through international
institutions,
through the creation of
an international court,
international criminal
court in 1998
that would have jurisdiction
not just for war crimes,
but crimes against humanity,
state aggression
and these things.
But this was a path that
sort of perfectly conformed
to our preferences, but also
to our historical lessons.
And so we could universalize
the rather difficult,
peculiar German history.
And this feeling, this
sense of being in sync
with history started to
crumble I think really in 2014,
and there was, if you go back
now you can see the signs
on the wall earlier, of
course, but the real,
the actual that it hit
home I think the invasion
and annexation of Crimea
and the Russian aggression
in Eastern Ukraine and
the Donbas was the sign
that the happy days
of post-wall Europe
and international
order were really over.
And then suddenly once you
realized that you also realized
that Russia had already
years before begun
to define its own future,
actually more in opposition
to the West, and no
longer in cooperation
or on a path of convergence.
And at the same it was
actually also true for China
under the new President
Xi Jinping
who would still modernize, still
grow, but not open, rather close
and become more repressive.
And there's sort of a far
more competitive element
in the international system
than we'd like to believe.
But these were still all
outside pressures and datapoints
that signaled the problem.
I think 2016, first
with the BREXIT and then
with the election
of the US President,
represented a different
dimension.
I mean the BREXIT decision ran
directly counter to the notion
that the process of integration
in Europe had something
that was irreversible,
that was sort of necessary,
that it conformed to
a historical pattern
of ever deeper integration.
And the British said, oh, we
can actually turn-off and go off
in the opposite direction, which
is a serious blow for Europe
but also a serious blow to
the way we Germans looked
at Europe and Europe's future.
And with the election of an
American President who would go
out in public, he and his top
advisors, and say there is no
such thing as an international
community, everybody is
out there for him or herself,
to look after him or herself,
that ran directly counter
to the second grand German
lesson of never alone.
So, as Ivan said, there are
other countries who can go back
to a more national
conception of their own country
in the international system.
You know, the French have their
goalist tradition of France
and the world that looks
after itself, but for Germany
that doesn't really
exist anymore
because all these more national
conceptions have all been
contaminated in the Nazi years
and they now basically belong
to the political fringes in
Germany's political system
for all the mainstream parties,
all those centrous parties.
There is nothing but a
multilateralist foreign policy
that looks at Germany's future
always linked to its neighbors,
but limited but also
legitimized in organizations
that include partners.
And that is why I would say
there's no other country
that I could think of that is
as challenged by the world view
as it is articulated by
the current US President
as is Germany, that in itself
looks at itself so much
as an American post-war
creation.
And this conceptual challenge
now to imagine the world
and our role in the world at
a moment when our own lessons
of history and the course
of the international political
system sort of diverge
after we thought they
would be, they would run
in parallel forever hopefully,
but certainly for longer
than it did is a pretty
painful situation in Germany
and it's just starting a
foreign policy debate of, well,
what is then Germany's
role and what should it do?
And most of that
points to Europe,
invest in the European
Union, invest in a network
of multilaterally
oriented nations,
and that is where
Ivan's point comes in.
You can sort of a national
political system can survive a
populist challenge,
maybe sometimes a populist
government can even help to sort
of correct or redefine the
national political landscape,
the issues that are important,
and then sort of it moves on.
It is quite difficult to imagine
the same for the European Union
because if you think of
it it is made up of 28
and once the British have
left 27 member states,
and it's working around
a table in Brussels
where all these countries
larger and smaller come together
and basically hammer out a
compromise that is, of course,
always imperfect but that
is based on the assumption
that in the longer term and if
you define national interests
in a wider perspective it is
beneficial to all of them.
And if you narrow your
definition of national interest
and you shorten the time
horizon then what you do is you
basically close the space, the
space shrinks for compromise
around the Brussels table
until it disappears entirely.
Everyone is only looking
after his or her own interests
on this very day, on this very
issue that is on the table
and not considering that
you may need the partners
and their enlightened
self-interests the next day,
then there is no room for
compromise or it shrinks
to a degree where it makes the
European Union actually look
like a body that is not able
to produce any meaningful
solution for any real problem.
So I think for me this
is it's really a question
of how you define
national interests,
there's a great expression
in Tocqueville's Democracy
in America where he talks of the
self-interest rightly understood
and I think you can
define self-interest
in very different ways.
And the Germans have learned
this lesson in a hard way
that we're better off today
and in this integrated Europe
than at any point in our history
before and it has something
to do with trying to define
our won self-interests in a way
that actually includes
the interests of neighbors
and partners and
others on the continent
and in taking a longer view.
And what puzzles us now
is that not just here
in the United States,
but also elsewhere
in the world national
interest is defined
in an increasingly narrow
and short-term perspective
and that leaves us
in a situation
where the solution we thought we
had found to the German problem
of being the biggest
country in the center
of the European Continent too
big to be just one among many,
but not big enough and strong
enough to rule all others,
that solution may not be as
permanent as we had hoped.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Thank you very much.
I do believe we are going
to have time to discuss it,
because some of the more
radical Euro skeptics are going
to ask questions like this.
Yugoslavia did not manage to
survive the end of the cold war
because the very existence of
the state was very much embedded
in a certain type of
international context,
could European Union
become the major victim,
is it through disintegration
of the EU,
of the end of a liberal order
as an international environment?
And I do believe this is a
fair question and this is why
for us basically what
Europeans are asking about this,
this is in a way we're much
more nervous than many others.
But the interesting story
about liberal order was
that it was always about the
relations between states,
but also what is
happening within the states.
And when people have
been very positive
on the liberal order
starting with the beginning
of the 21st Century one of the
critical countries was Turkey.
Opening of Turkey was
critical for something
that is happening
simply between states,
but how the new relations
between states is starting
basically to change things.
And we're going to
have basically the view
of what is happening,
the Turkish perspective
of these relations between the
foreign and domestic politics
and talking about one
of the key countries
that in a way also
symbolizes something
that can become problematic with
the crisis of the liberal order.
And Solly Roselle [assumed
spelling] is the person
to say this.
>> Solly Roselle: Well,
I prepared other notes,
but if you want me to talk
about those I'll talk.
>> Ivan Krastev: This is
the problem with Turkey,
also as indicated, they
always prepare other notes.
>> Solly Roselle: Yes, okay.
I mean Turkey's behavior
today cannot be dissociated
with what has gone
in the past 30 years.
It's interesting, in eight
months' time it will be 30th
anniversary of Francis
Fukuyama's article published
in national interest.
And although Fukuyama wrote
a lot more and recently kind
of distanced himself from 30
years ago I guess he will always
be remembered or damned because
of the end of history article,
which of course ended like his
doctoral dissertation advisor
Huntington's article
with a question mark.
And that question mark
of course we dismiss.
And in a way for both of those
articles, that is end of history
and the clash of civilizations,
Turkey was a critical country
because it actually was
always and partially
because of the geography
on which it sat a
Janus-faced country.
And in a way Turkey also
showed a lot of adaptability
to the requirements of the new
order that was emerging in 1989,
wasted the 1990s, and then
almost reinvented itself.
And I have to say that the
Clinton Administration was,
mainly thanks to the
late Richard Holbrook,
understood Turkey's role and
actually pushed the country,
pushed the European Union and
pushed American foreign policy
to encourage Turkey to actually
play that, not the bridge role,
bridge in my judgment is
really the wrong metaphor
because bridges don't
belong anywhere,
but Turkey as a mediator,
a country that could
actually speak the language
of the three regions
that surround it.
And what I call Turkey
surrounded or at the center
of what I call three
geopolitical ecosystems,
the European one, Russia,
central Asia caucus is one,
and of course the Middle East.
Ecosystem in the Middle East
may not be fitting these days,
but still.
And Turkey, to the extent
that Turkey could rise
to the occasion and
manage to actually mediate
between those three, then it
would have accomplished its role
and that is precisely almost
in so many words how
Richard Holbrook defined it
and the Clinton Administration
tried to push us
and the Europeans
in that direction.
In fact, in an article he wrote
in 1994 for Foreign Affairs,
which he had a strange kind
of because Holbrook wrote,
during the cold war Germany
was the frontline state,
in the post cold war period
Turkey is the frontline state,
when there was no war
or the threat of war,
so what was the front, what
did the war consist of?
And that was, of course, to
avoid what Huntington raised,
clashal civilizations.
Maybe this was formulated
wrongly,
I mean in retrospect I would
think it was, but no doubt
that issue of identity
starting with the dissolution
of the Yugoslavia, the
Yuan Dong massacres,
and all that had actually been
with us and actually hunting us
and we are now dissociating
ourselves from it
because interest has come back.
I wish to take a detour
before I go back to Turkey
and to talk a bit about
the United States,
since our topic is
hypocrisy in our project.
I have a very hard
time personally
to accept the bemoaning
of many liberals today
that the Trump Administration's
policies are ending the liberal
world order.
First of all, five
years ago we didn't talk
about the liberal world order.
And, secondly and
much more importantly,
who broke that order?
Many of the people today
who lament the passing
of the liberal world order were
cheerleaders for the Iraq war,
whether they came from the right
or they came from the left.
They were the intellectual
promoters of an act
by the most powerful country
in the world at the time
to break the rules that
actually itself formulated
at the beginning of
the cold war era.
We really cannot have an
intelligent or a fair discussion
about Russia and what it does,
about China and what it does,
about Turkey and what it does,
we doubt accepting the fact
that the rules in a major
way were first broken
by that country which
actually set them.
And it will be very
difficult in my judgment
under those circumstances
to put Humpty Dumpty
back together, okay?
Secondly, we also have
to acknowledge in my view
and I hear what Thomas has
said literally and then
but I also add to it there
was a sense of complacency
and that's what the end of
history debate was all about.
We've reached the search,
the end of the search,
there will be nothing
better which blinded those
who actually benefited
from the unilateral moment,
it blinded them to
the inequities
that the economic system
generated, it blinded them
to the dialectic
of globalization
that everybody championed.
That is you could not
have a win-win result
from globalization forever,
and it turned out that those
who support for the liberal
order and it was necessary,
that is the working people
of developed countries ended
up on the losing side of that
development and in return,
of course, millions,
hundreds of millions of people
in the developing world
actually benefitted immensely,
but those who ruled those,
I mean the developed countries
did not take into account
that the legitimacy of what
they were pursuing depended
on taking care of those who
were actually being left behind.
And I'm not certain that that
blindness has been cured,
even now, because without
understanding this we really
cannot understand or begin
to treat the populist rage,
whether it is of a leftist
kind or a rightest kind.
Secondly, not to be reductionist
in terms of inequities,
I mean economic inequalities,
obviously the top
of a liberal order also
reflected a certain
understanding of what the
culture of that order was
and I guess one does get carried
away with one's own rhetoric
and beliefs and you
start belittling those
who do not necessarily
fit your own description
of what the ideal life or ideal
identity ought to be like.
And now once the vase is broken
these are really very difficult
things to fix.
I mean Germany's
unemployment rate is what, 3.8,
Austria's is probably
below zero, I don't know.
The United States today
is at 3.7 and all that.
And if it was even more
equitably done once those
questions have been put on
stage it's very difficult
to actually change the
conversation back to one
where you use the terms
that you used to be using.
So we've got to accept that.
And coming to Rosa's question,
do we go back to what we used
to have once the blip is over?
The blip may not be over,
that's one thing and, second,
even if it is over we cannot
go back, I mean we're back
to Ancient Greece, right, you
cannot take, we don't get baited
in the same way but twice, okay?
And the Greeks have a lot of
wisdom to give us on that.
So coming to Turkey, Turkey
of course is a very flexible
country or it can be.
Okay, we will play the
dialogue of civilization scarred
and we will give the
European Union a chance
as the European Union was
going to give us a chance,
and I must say for a very,
in retrospect of course,
for a fleeting moment both sides
actually dropped the hypocrisy,
double talk and insincerity that
defined their relations forever.
Very fleeting moment.
I wish that both those who were
in positions of responsibility
in the European Union and those
in Turkey actually truly
understood the meaning
and the potency of that moment
and actually went ahead with it.
That wasn't to be, we're now
back to our usual positions.
But in between, though,
because of the weakening
of the international system,
and I personally do not talk
in terms of the return
of geopolitics,
I'm more comfortable with
geopolitics finally waking
up from a long sleep because
I don't think geopolitics
ever died.
The United States exercised it.
With the return of geopolitics,
declining American power
and the colossal failures of
the Iraq war Turkey, of course,
repossessed for itself
an identity
that it is usually
very comfortable with,
and that is a post-imperial
power which wishes
to become an important not
to be ignored regional power.
And I must say I also detect
in Turkey a post-imperial
trauma syndrome.
I guess Mr. Cooper could
understand me well,
they lost an empire as well.
The thing is our trauma
really came a bit late,
about nine years later, and
now we're trying to make-up
for lost time and,
therefore, all of the regions
that surround us are for
Turkey fair playing in terms
of projecting Turkey's
power and vision
of I guess hegemonic domination.
And whether or not Turkey will
be able to do that still is
out in the open, but
I'll start, I'll conclude
with what I'm sure
most of you at least
with some interest are
following, what happened
to Mr. Khashoggi and what kind
of policy Turkey is
pursuing in that?
I have to say the
Khashoggi affair fits right
into our project.
There was a murder, a
rather gruesome one.
It is now I guess pretty obvious
that the Turkish
Government was aware of it,
the British Government
knew about it in advance,
and unless the American
intelligence was
as usual sleeping on the job
they must also have had some
inclination as to what
was going to happen.
And, therefore, we are now
playing a game and the game,
therefore, beyond
the moral aspects
of the murder this
has now become a dance
between three partners.
How will Turkey treat
Saudi Arabia?
How will Turkey or will
the United States side
with the Turkish
narrative and then dump MBS,
or as the President said
initially I have arms to sell,
I really cannot jeopardize that?
That remains to be seen.
I mean again he was not
hypocritical, but it's obvious
that for this particular
issue at least
for the moment the American
political system for a variety
of reasons and American media
and maybe civil society are
not going to let this go.
And if, indeed, this leads to
a dumping of MBS as a result
that will really be a victory
for a noncynical approach
to power relations.
And if with all the
problems that it had
so far Turkey I think
managed it relatively well,
protecting national interests
but also keeping interest alive
and also giving enough
information.
And at the end of the day this
may turn out to be the defining
or a decisive moment
for the Middle East
to see whether it will
be the Saudi version
over an Islamic power or a
Turkish version of a Sunni power
that is going to
have more of a say
in the future order
of the Middle East.
Don't count on order in
the Middle East, though.
Thank you.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Thank you very much.
I need just to go and to
take any type of a comment,
any type of a question, not
just answer one-by-one but try
to make it much more
as a discussion
and then going back
to the panel.
I just want to stress one thing
that I do believe is interesting
for at least our starting
point when we started.
Every order goes for crisis
and being changed and so
from this point there is
nothing that is happening
that is historic than expected.
But if you go back to 1989,
1990s the major story was
that this was a kind
of a world order
which everybody is going
to feel victorious.
And though on the level of
the rhetoric it is not simply
that the West has
won the cold war,
that the Russian people
has won the cold war
against the communist regime
and everybody was winning.
Thirty years later everybody
identified as a victim
and loser, Russia to be honest
is the most obvious case,
but then you go into central and
eastern Europe particularly some
of the populist government who
said we lost, and then suddenly
with President Trump the
Americans said we are the
biggest victim of the world that
the American created in 1989.
And for me this type of an
important transformation
of the world which was a win-win
and now is lose-lose is
something to be taken seriously
because it is also trying
to throw not simply a kind
of a language, but
this is something
that Simon Vale [assumed
spelling] is going
to define cheap collective
imagination.
Suddenly you start to see the
world totally differently.
Something that till
yesterday was looking
as an advantage starts to see
as disadvantage, vulnerability.
We are finishing the book
with Steven Hobbs [assumed
spelling] this was the reason I
was here, I'll give just one
example, English language.
Fifteen years ago everybody is
going to claim that the spread
of the English language
was the best demonstration
of the American soft power.
You go everywhere
and you're going
to hear somebody
speaking English.
And then suddenly the spread
of the English language starts
to be perceived as
America's vulnerability.
Why? I'm just going to
give you three examples.
Because if everybody speaks
English everybody knows how
America functions, but America
is not very aware how other
people function.
It is easier for everybody to go
onto social media and to pretend
to be an American, it is not
easy for the Americans to go
onto social media and to
pretend being Bulgarians.
Secondly, on the level of
knowledge the fact that you have
so many English speakers
in different countries,
you go to a country you're
always going to find somebody
who speaks English and you
have the feeling that you talk
to the local population.
But not always the
English speakers
which are self-selected groups
are very much representatives
for the general kind
of understanding
in the very general
mode of the country.
So certainly, strangely enough,
which was America's biggest kind
of advantage starts to be
perceived asymmetry, vulnerable,
everybody can interfere in our
politics and we find it more
and more difficult to interfere
in the politics of others
because we don't know
what is going on.
This type of change is for
me critically important.
Something that you liked
yesterday you start
to fear today.
This is also east
European example,
you go on the opinion polls,
ask the east Europeans
what is the best thing
that happened to you after 1989?
And they are going to tell
you opening of the borders.
Ask them after the
refugee crisis,
what is the things
that you fear most?
Opening of the borders.
And from this point of view
the fact where the best
and the worst happened
to be the same.
Is a kind of miss in the
important political reality
that we are talking about,
but I am going to stop here.
Please feel free
to ask, to comment,
and basically then we'll
go back to the panel.
Please? Yes, there should
be a microphone, yes.
>> Thank you, this
is very interesting.
I have a whole bunch of
questions, I'll limit to two.
First, on the question of
BREXIT, Theresa May was opposed
to the idea of BREXIT
at the beginning,
but when she took office she
promised she would implement it,
of course she's taken
forever to do so,
and I'm wondering is she trying
to get someone to force her
to call a new referendum to
try to reverse the decision?
That's question number one.
Question number two
for Ms. Brooks,
you talk about whether the
US will return to normal
and I'm just wondering
what is normal?
Was George W. Bush's
Administration normal?
Was the Obama Administration
normal?
Is there such a thing as normal?
>> Ivan Krastev: Yes, please?
>> John Van Houdt: Thank you
for those presentations,
very interesting.
My name is John Van Houdt
and I'm from The Library
of Congress, I worked
on European politics
for a long time.
This is a comment, but
feel free to comment
on the comment, if you would.
I think hypocrisy is a very
interesting conceptual way
to look at it, particularly
when it's Putin versus the West
or whatever, but from an
internal Western perspective I
think a useful way to
look at it is laziness.
I think it strikes me how
lazy the elites of the West
who talk endlessly about this
liberal international order how
sort of lack of effort
they've put
into even understanding
what creating
and maintaining that order was.
I mean I just, I could give many
examples, but I'd just give one.
The Bretton Wood system,
you have to read article
after article after article in
which Eikenberry and others go
on and on and on about
the alphabet soup
of the Bretton Wood system.
How hard people like the
young Paul Volker used to work
to maintain the convertibility
of the dollar into gold
at $35 an ounce and not keep the
whole system from crashing down,
and it was just really
hard work.
Now Germany runs a $300
billion trade surplus,
the US runs a $500
billion trade deficit,
it goes on and on and on.
The IMF is a bunch of well-paid
bureaucrats who give advice
to mostly developing countries
and occasionally a country
like Greece, but there's no
really hard work that goes
into maintaining a
difficult costly world order.
And so what we've simultaneously
done is put less and less effort
into maintaining that order and
made it more and more expansive,
both geographically it's
supposed to apply to everybody,
everybody except a few rogues,
to use the lingo of the '90s,
and also more and more areas
in our national criminal court,
Kyoto and so on and so forth.
So there's a kind
of a now a laziness,
we invoke the international
order
but we don't put
much effort into it.
Now the cold war, of
course, imposed discipline,
it was partly if
the dollar goes,
if we go off the gold standard
or whatever the world is going
to come to an end that's
what people like Johnson
and Eisenhower thought
and so on.
So the East-West conflict
imposed a discipline,
maybe it was just a
different sociology and so on,
but I do think we have a
problem not only with hypocrisy
but also with kind of effort.
And the European Union
is a wonderful thing,
but it does kind of
and enlargement cost
and it was not cheap and
so on, but it does kind
of spin-out lots and
lots and lots of projects
that sound great, but
how much real effort goes
into actually reality.
Anyway, that's a comment,
but I would like anybody
to comment on it, as well.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Thank you very much.
There was a question there?
Yes, please?
>> How do you see
global capitalism fitting
into these shifts that
you're talking about?
>> Ivan Krastev: Thank you.
Please?
>> In regards to
Germany you mentioned
that the nationalist identity
is so rooted in history
that Germany is now defined by
an international liberal order.
If Germany were to shift back
to the national identity
do you see some
of that extremism still coming
up and what are your comments
on extremism that has arisen in
Germany, the neo-Nazi sentiment?
And in regards to Turkey with
the resent Sochi agreements
and action in Syria how has
that impacted Russia's relations
with Turkey and Turkey's
relations
with the US and the EU?
>> Ivan Krastev: Thank you.
Yes, question, next to you?
>> Topaden [assumed spelling],
I hope said it right, did I?
>> Ivan Krastev: Yes.
>> Would it be better for
American foreign policy
if more Americans,
especially foreign policymakers
and politicians, instead of
speaking English while abroad
if they know French or
know German or know Polish,
that's becoming very popular
to learn, and they spoke
in those languages instead,
would that be a way to almost
from the bottom up start
to rebuild the international
community
and a sense of global
solidarity?
Because instead of everyone
else speaking English it'd be
like us being, you know, I'm
going to speak your language
or I'm going to learn
a little bit of yours
and it'll build connections
that may help solidify the
international community
to become more pro-democratic
and more working together
in solidarity like
it used to be.
>> Ivan Krastev: Thank you.
Probably this is
the last question,
I believe I'm not
missing something here.
>> Hi. Thank you so much
for all of your comments.
I was thinking about what you
said with in terms of hypocrisy
and like how it's
represented now in the US.
In terms of education and
raising this new generation
to think about American
hypocrisy how do you think
that's going to work?
Is it so embedded in our
institutions that even
like the education we receive
at this point kind of represents
that or do you think
that there's a way
that that can be applied broadly
in education moving forward
for the new generation?
Thank you.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Thank you very much.
We're basically back
from Turkey to Britain,
the imperial arc this
time the other way,
and we try to be very concise.
On your question
about languages,
which is critically important,
Carl Schmidt [assumed
spelling] was somebody
that Germans normally are not
going to quote, he used to say
that Victoria's powers tends
to [inaudible] curiosity.
Part of the problem is
the history story is
that you're not very much
interested in the world
because they're coming to you,
one day they're going to be
like you, you know what
they're going to be,
why are you interested
who they are?
And from this point it was
very different than the kind
of knowledge dynamics
during the cold war.
If you see the affect
of the Sputnik
on the way basically the
Americans get the feeling
that they don't know
the other side,
everybody was learning
languages, you have the feeling
that there is something very
important that you should learn.
Now you to go your countries
and what you're seeing basically
is what they don't have.
You come to Bulgaria
and they said,
they don't have [inaudible]
they don't have this,
they don't have that.
In a certain way you're
starting basically
to understand countries on the
base of how different they are
from what they're
going to be sometime.
And this is not good
from the knowledge base,
and I very much agree
with you, it's not simply
that you should learn the
language but basically it means
that you should very much try to
understand how society functions
and not how dysfunctional they
are from your point of view,
and this is a different story.
Of course, knowing the
English language also creates
on the outside world the
talk of the false image
that you understand
the United States,
and particularly it could
be a very cynical image.
There is a well-known quote
when Mr. Shroyko [assumed
spelling] was promoted
to become the Minister
of Defense
of the Russian Federation he
had a talk with President Putin
and Putin told him,
listen, you're now going
to do the international
relations, you're going to deal
with the Americans, you
don't need to do too much,
just watch the house of cards.
And this is part of
the story that, okay,
house of cards probably
is telling you something
about the United States,
but if you're going
to make all your policies
towards the United States just
based on watching the house
of cards this also can turn
to be not the greatest
idea, but I'll go to Solly.
>> Solly Roselle: You want
to find out Turkey's policy
in Syria and its
closeness to Russia, well,
Turkey made a number
of miscalculations
and I think it's a tribute
to its geopolitical position
that despite those errors it is
still as they call at the table.
The major error Turkey
committed, apart from thinking
that Assad would go easily,
was to attack a Russian plane
thinking that this might lead
to a mobilization of
NATO on its side in order
to actually pursue
its policies in Syria.
It didn't work, in fact,
in return the Russians kind
of punished Turkey, and in the
meantime the United States,
Turkey's ally, has
gotten even more intimate
with Turkey's sworn enemies,
that is the PKK's
Syrian branch, PYD.
That led Turkey to reconsider
its relations with Russia
and it also led the Russians
to reconsider their relations
with Turkey, which actually
was becoming a bit desperate.
And they allowed Turkey
to do a number of things
that Turkey could not without
Russian permission could do
in Syria.
So for the moment Turkey is
using America's indecisiveness
and kind of weakness and
the Russian's immense desire
to divorce Turkey from
NATO, playing both sides.
How long that can go on
I really do not know,
but so far Turkey was able
I think with both a blink
from the United States and
with the help of the Russians
to make sure that the
PYD could not control all
of its southern border.
And that to a certain
extent resolves Turkey's
security problem.
And from this point onwards
what will happen between Turkey
and Russia and between Turkey
and the United States will
be determined in my judgment
by also what happens between
Russia and the United States
for the conclusion of
the Syrian debacle.
My sense is that peace is
not to come very soon and if
that is the case
Turkey will continue
to be administering the areas
that its military operations
actually made it possible
for it to occupy.
>> Ivan Krastev: Thomas?
>> Thomas Bagger: Yes, I'll
try to make two points.
The first one to
the laziness charge
and the languages question.
I think this sort of laziness,
it relates a bit
to what Ivan said.
We were very good with grand
generalizations and again
to the argument I tried to
make earlier, if you believe
that everyone else becomes
like you you don't have
to study their peculiar
circumstances, right?
Why they think what they
think, how they got there,
and how they will, how they
look at their own future.
So just one example in the
cold war understanding Moscow
and the Kremlin was
existential for Germany
and there was quite a bit of
intellectual and academic effort
and resources put into that.
After 1989 we dissolved
most of these institutions,
it was no longer interesting.
They would modernize and
eventually, you know,
they would become like us and
we could speak English with them
about how long it would
take them to get there.
Now two years ago we
recreated an Institute
for Eastern European and
International Studies
because we realized this
is not going to happen.
There was a laziness certainly
in the assumption that we had
or in our expectation, and we
need to understand the debates,
the intellectual concepts in
places, not just like Russia
but also in central Asia, in
eastern Europe sort of east
of the European Union.
So in that sense I
would go along with you.
In a different way I don't think
the charge is entirely fair
because it is also true
that international relations
today compared to the days
when they conceptualized the
Brattenwood's [assumed spelling]
institutions is infinitely
more complex, more states,
more interdependence, more
interaction, more stakeholders,
not states only but
others as well.
Just take the climate
negotiations as one example.
So there's an infinite necessity
to invest time and energy
to sort of produce the solutions
or the way forward for problems
that are no longer, that you
can't solve on a national
or even the level of
20 states let's say.
So I would argue that sort of
the task ahead of people who try
to do this today it's a
tall order and it's not
that they just sit back, neither
in Brussels nor elsewhere,
but maybe that's sort of
my own defensive nature
because I'm part of a
government organization.
>> Ivan Krastev: You're lazy.
>> Thomas Bagger: And I
hate to be called lazy, yes.
The other point is
to the immigration,
nationalism question,
but it also goes to sort
of the global capitalism
question.
You know, clearly Germany is
also experiencing currently a
repolarization of the
political landscape.
For decades the pendulum swung
a different direction in Germany
and in the United States.
The story I told earlier, when I
was studying here in 1989, 1990,
this was a very centrist
political discourse,
very civil in the US.
It was much more polarized
around the division
of my country in Germany.
After unification we became,
we had a very centrist
political system able
to integrate the extremes.
That's why we had grand
coalitions in Germany
where essentially the former
left and former right party,
the Christian democrats
and social democrats,
they could easily
form a coalition
because they all subscribed
to this general idea
that you basically just need
the best technocratic solution,
but there were no big
ideological fights
to fight anymore.
Whereas here in the US the
development went exactly the
other way.
So now we see a repolarization
of the German political
landscape and it has a lot to do
with the immigration question,
with the identity question.
And I would say that because
both big parties are suffering
and leading voters to
the polls of the debate.
But these polls of the debate
that we see are no longer
in the sort of the classic left,
right spectrum of politics,
doesn't help you to
understand really anymore.
It's far more, it's sort
of like a different axis
that defines open versus closed.
And if you think about identity
do you think of something
that you need to protect,
that you need to close off
against foreigners or others,
those who are not part of it,
whether that's an
ethnic definition
or a culturalist definition,
people who cannot
possibly become part of it?
Or do you look at identity more
as a resource and says, look,
this is what Germany has to
offer, for everyone who is able
to read not just
Goethe or Schiller,
but listen to German music,
read German intellectuals?
It's actually an open
resource that can help you
to relate better to your own
culture, to your own thinking
about the world, and you have
a much more open perspective.
And that's what I
see developing,
that that's the spectrum along
which political forces
are aligning themselves,
and clearly also in Germany you
have those that basically want
to tell sort of the story
of a victim and we need
to protect ourselves
from attacks from outside
or from others and from
immigration and so forth.
And that is what gets me to
the global capitalism question,
as well, and I think,
Solly, you mentioned it
in your first statement.
That sort of our blindness to
the dialectics of globalization,
to the inequities, to the
incredible loss of credibility
of the Western model or
the Western order that came
with the financial
crisis of 2008.
I mean many of these
other countries,
they looked at the West
not necessarily with a lot
of sympathy, but with this idea
that they're richer than we are,
they also may be freer than
we are, they're more efficient
than we are, but certainly
they know what they're doing.
And if not in Iraq with the
Iraq war or in the Middle East
at least economically
financially they knew what
they're doing.
And it turns out we
didn't, and this is not just
at a state level, but
lots of economic actors
who were actually
gaming a system
that they didn't
understand, that they created
but they couldn't control
and didn't understand,
with massive repercussions for
lots of other people who tried
to make a living every
day with their job.
I think we still underestimate
how much this contributed,
the 2008 crisis, in the eyes
of the Chinese and the Russians
and others to say
that's not the future,
they don't represent the future,
they don't even know
what they're doing.
And so I think this question of
what is the role of the state
in regulating the
affects of globalization,
what do future trade
agreements have to look like,
how do we regulate technology
and technological disruptions
so that it doesn't
destroy the social fabric
and doesn't only profit a
few globalized companies?
All of these questions
are back on the agenda,
and I think there's a
pretty broad consensus now,
but when you look back
clearly many people were sort
of oblivious to the challenges
that globalization was actually
piling up in front of us
until sort of we, until
we hit the wall with it.
So in that sense I think
these two are related
because if you want to keep sort
of the good parts of openness
as a society, but
also as an economy
or as a political system,
because I think we
do need cooperation,
not just for prosperity but
also for problem solving
on the international stage, but
then you have to make a case
that you can do that
also in a just way,
in a way that satisfy
the largest number.
And otherwise those who will
argue for a closed system
and you only look after yourself
and basically everyone is
out there just to get
the better of you,
then that will win the day.
And I think part of the, you
always have this group in each
and every society, Germany
but also every other country,
I think the stunning
realization in 2016 in Britain
or in the US was that that
can actually be enough to take
over and govern a country.
>> Ivan Krastev: Rosa?
>> Rosa Brooks: Yes, let
me start with the question
of whether the US can
go back to normal?
What is normal?
I don't think we
can for two reasons.
One being that you can't step
into the same river twice,
it's a different river
and you're a different person
reason, but also I think
that the normal was as
we've been saying so full
of contradictions that we
weren't acknowledging it was an
unsustainable state of affairs.
And I see Trump in many
ways less as a cause
than as a symptom or maybe
it's Trump is the equivalent
of pouring gasoline on a fire,
but that fire was
already smoldering,
it's just that under
Trump it's now a
full-fledged conflagration.
But I think even without,
I think all of the forces
that brought us to
the moment that we're
in were there before
the election
of 2016 in the United States.
We saw them in Europe,
we saw them in other
parts of the world.
And I suppose this connects
to the laziness point
in that I share Solly's
eyerolling
over the sudden nostalgia and
insistence that we must shore-up
and preserve the
international liberal order.
It's like the old quip about the
holy Roman Empire being neither
holy nor Roman nor an Empire,
that the international
liberal order it turns
out was neither entirely
international.
There were entire
states and peoples
that were left entirely
out of it.
Nor was it particularly liberal,
nor was it very orderly
as it happens.
And if we are too lazy or
unimaginative or blinded
to acknowledge that, you
know, that's the first step
in Alcoholics Anonymous,
they say the first step
is acknowledging you have
a problem.
You know, if we can't even go
that first step and acknowledge
to ourselves that the
international liberal order was
never looked like Cary Grant,
to switch to Ivan's metaphor,
then I don't know how we
go about resolving any
of those internal
contradictions.
And I was reminded when you
were talking of my favorite,
of the role that, as you say,
the United States played a
significant role in undermining,
in making sure that that
order would not be fully
international, liberal
or orderly
through actions such
as the Iraq war.
I was reminded of one of
my favorite Putin quotes,
which I think I quoted
to my friends
in the hypocrisy study
group on previous occasions.
Vladimir Putin always
quotable when, and this was not
over the Iraq war, but when
Kosovo declared independence
unilaterally and, of course, the
United States along with most
of the EU states had said, no,
no, no, Russia, don't worry,
we are not going to support
Kosovo independence from Serbia,
absolutely not, we support
Serbian sovereignty, et cetera.
And then when Kosovo
unilaterally declared
independence and the EU and the
United States immediately said,
okay, we recognize
Kosovo independence,
Vladimir Putin said something,
this is not a direct quote
but it was more or
less along these lines,
he said you Americans,
you Europeans,
those of you recognizing
Kosovo's independence,
you do not understand, you
are overturning 200 years
of international norms
about sovereignty
and you do not understand
this is a two-sided stick
and the other end will come
back and hit you in the face.
And, of course, a few
years later in Crimea
that stick did come back
and hit us in the face,
and he wasn't wrong to
level that critique.
It does, one of the things that
depresses me most is I do think
that in this country, we've
been talking about this
with our friend and
colleague, Steve Walt,
one thing that depresses me
most is the I think inability
of the sort of mainstream
foreign policy elites
and also Democratic Party
elites to grapple with any
of those contradictions.
And it pains me to say
that I still see these
statements coming
out of my favorite
Washington liberal think tanks
and organizations where
you'll get this sort
of unblushing contradictions
where you'll sort
of simultaneously
say we recognize
that endless war is not good for
our nation and so we will work
to end these wars, we recognize
that terrorism is a scourge
to the whole world and so
we will pursue terrorists
to the end of the earth.
And you think wait a
second, hold on, you know,
how are you going to
do both of those things
because if you think both of
those, that's not going to work.
And yet I think that we are
still lazy or still blinded,
there is a fantasy that
there is a sustainable normal
that we can simply
revert to and just edit
out this whole business of
Trump and this whole nationalism
and populism business
and it really isn't.
The final question I think and
I'm sure I'm missing several,
but about young people and
how do we educate young people
to not be quite as hypocritical
and not be quite as lazy?
I almost worry, and I
have two teenaged children
and I watch them, that
they are so deeply aware
of American hypocrisy that I
worry it becomes paralyzing.
You know, that they do not think
of the United States as a force
for global good, they
think of the US as a force
for global disruption
and inequality,
and of course they're
right to think that,
but I do worry a little bit
that that leads to a sort
of sense of paralysis.
It's not laziness, it's
depression, it's a sense of, oh,
well, we're out of big
ideas, communism didn't work,
the great American
experiment didn't work,
the international liberal order
wasn't so liberal or orderly,
you know, we're out of ideas.
And I don't quite know how
to urge them and urge others
in their generation,
urge the students I teach
to say don't give
up, don't be lazy,
but don't stop being
creative and imaginative
or then we really are done.
And if there is a bright
side to Donald Trump
and the various other Trump-like
conflagrations that we're seeing
around the globe
today, you know,
it's the old saying what does
not kill us makes us strong.
If this doesn't completely
blow things
up I think it does create some
potential space for people
to break out of those old
left, right dichotomies
because they have
proven inadequate.
And I hope, I love to see
young people viewing this more
as a clarion call
to say, all right,
those old ideas did not
work, what's the next set
of big ideas, and that's going
to be your job to
figure them out.
>> Robert Cooper: I
think I would rather go
for little ideas actually.
I think the big ideas are the
ones that get us into trouble.
But I think that the
world can be made better,
but I think that it's mostly
made better bit by bit.
And I think that the US played
an absolutely fantastic,
stunning, indispensable
role in that
and one ought to remember that.
You can see it, if you have
to and now there are lots of,
and when the US makes mistakes
it makes gigantic mistakes.
My personal view has always been
that the first duty of Europe is
to stop the US from doing
really stupid things,
and that's why actually it
would be better if the UK was
in the EU because,
but still I would --
if you're European you can't
forget how the US handled
post-war Europe, it's
actually a miracle.
So maybe I can just answer
one or two of the other?
>> Solly Roselle: I
wanted to add one sentence.
You did mention getting
into EU I think at 90 some.
And I think what he says that
is important for the next thing,
we're still in the
era of Ronald Reagan,
that is government
is not the solution,
government is the problem.
And what Paul Walker
was saying was we have
to make public service
valuable again.
That is in my view
part of the answer.
I just wanted to add that.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Robert, just I come back
because I have it stuck
in my head, in 19 --
I'm not very good at
the dates, it's in 1943
or something like that.
>> 20th Century.
>> Ivan Krastev: 20th Century.
>> Anyway, I wasn't yet, but
still in 1943 the German who was
in charge of running Denmark
as an occupied territory
in World War II received
an instruction
to solve the Jewish question.
He almost certainly knew
that the third secretary
in the German Embassy, George
Dukfitz [assumed spelling],
was going to inform
the community leaders
in Denmark what was coming.
And so when the Gestapo arrived
to arrest the Jews
they found only 200.
Well, that was 200 too
many, but the rest escaped.
And the reason why, it's
not absolutely clear,
and I forget his name, whether
the man who was in charge
of Denmark at the time
told Dukfitz to do this
but I'm pretty sure that he
guessed what was happening.
And the reason why was because
over the horizon they could see
the US coming.
And the guess that you made at
the point that this order went
out was you guessed that the US,
that the world was probably
going to be a liberal world.
And, well, he got a lot of
debits on his balance sheet
and he wanted to try and
finish with one credit.
And I think that it was even
the looming presence of the US
at that stage in the war
was a good influence,
and there's much,
much more behind that.
So that's just intervention
because it happened
to be in my head.
But I want just to come back
to one or two of the questions.
First of all, the
mention of the IMF,
I think the IMF is
an interesting case
because the IMF was set-up
to do, to manage a system
which is completely
different from the one
that we have at the moment.
And you thought that this
system was being destroyed
with the Nixon chalk, as
they called it in Japan.
Actually it's not a bad thing
that we have a serious
international institution
that has some responsibility,
rather vague,
for the international
financial system.
It's not exactly a
lender of last resort,
that's Wall Street is the lender
of last resort, but the ability
to cooperate in financial crises
and the ability of the IMF
to steady national
crises and to deal,
to help Wall Street
basically at the moment deal
with real international crises.
I think that that's
actually indispensable
for the order at the moment.
So it wasn't what they
planned at Brettenwoods,
but it's I think still a very,
very valuable institution.
It makes mistakes like others
do, but learns like others do.
It's a good thing about
institutions, unlike men,
is that they sometimes learn.
Second, a remark on languages.
The British Ambassador
in Tehran,
way back when the
Shah was there,
said that when a British
Minister came to call
on the Shah and the Shah spoke
English, which he did perfectly,
it made his blood run cold
because the British Minister
would think he was dealing
with an English gentleman,
whereas, he was actually dealing
with somebody who was very
complicated and very different
from the way in which he
seemed when he spoke English.
Consequently, there's
a lot to be said for,
actually there's a lot to
be said for interpreters,
at least you know then
that you're dealing
with a foreign culture
and foreigners are not
necessarily exactly the same
as you.
So it's a pity that American
Presidents don't speak however
many languages that are left,
but it's several thousand.
But, well, they have diplomats
and other people
who can help them.
But one should never forget
that it's not just the language,
even if the language is the
same the ways of thinking
and the history and the
words, they're all different.
And then I come back to
the question that was kind
of in away for me, which
is a complicated one.
Theresa May, wow.
The demonstration I was at
last weekend there was somebody
carrying a sign saying,
hey, hey, Theresa May,
when will you let
us have our say?
This recalls the last
demonstration I went
on which was against
the Vietnam war,
in between I'd missed
the demonstrations, but.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Being in office.
>> Robert Cooper: Yes,
Theresa May was never planned
to be Prime Minister and
she was not intended by God
to be Prime Minister, but things
sometimes turn out that way.
And when she became
Prime Minister she knew
that she'd voted
for the other side,
but the first thing she
thought she'd better do is
to persuade the BREXITers
that she was one of them.
So she made some fire
breathing speeches
about how awful the European
Union was and said we were going
to leave absolutely everything
that we could possibly leave.
Actually she didn't
really know very much
about the European
Union at that point.
Nobody does, it's
only when you leave it
that you begin to understand it.
>> Ivan Krastev:
Like divorce, yes.
>> Robert Cooper:
Exactly, exactly.
She's been on this
voyage of discovery.
Everybody should, they say
no good marriage is complete
without one.
So everybody ought to try
and do a mock divorce early
on in their marriage and then
they would realize what they
were going to lose.
And she knew about one
specific sector quite well
and she operated it
quite efficiently,
it's a very narrow sector
concerned with things
like European arrest warrant
and very useful instruments
but a very narrow sector.
And she's been discovering
all kinds
of things she didn't
know before,
like about how a supply
chain works and the problems
of the Irish border,
all of these things
that she didn't know.
And I didn't know, too, even
though I worked 10 years.
The other thing that she's
learning is she's learning how
extraordinarily difficult
it is, first of all,
it's extraordinarily difficult
to negotiate with somebody
if you don't know what you want.
And her opening slogan of no
deal is better than a bad deal,
she didn't know what
she meant by a bad deal
and she certainly
didn't know what, quotes,
no deal was going to mean.
So this was completely vacuous
and you can't govern
just by slogans.
And now as the more
she discovers,
the more she discovers what is
disaster leaving the European
Union, potentially is for the
UK, and the more she's trying
to find ways around it.
But she's also discovering
that negotiating
with the European Union
is one definition of hell,
and negotiating with
the European Union
on absolutely everything and
all things that are vital
to your country is about as bad
as you can get in terms of hell.
It's the seventh
circle, or I don't know
which way the circles go,
anyway it's the hottest part.
And so it would have been better
if the UK hadn't
started the process
without knowing what it wanted
and how it was going
to get there.
But the point about the European
Union is it creates fantastic
solidarity among the
member states because,
as I think someone said earlier,
I think it was probably Thomas,
you're always going to need
somebody else's help the next
day, you can never afford
to break with everybody.
So if somebody has got
a problem that matters
to them then you really
take it into account,
you mold your policy around it.
The Irish care very, very deeply
about the Irish border
for very good reason.
The European Union will not
budge from supporting Ireland
because it's a member,
it's one of them.
So for the first time in
history we have Dublin,
which used to be
kicked around by London
because it was just a
rather difficult colony,
we have Dublin dictating
the terms to London.
The European Union is anybody
who wants anything now,
and the Spanish were talking
about whether they might
get Gibraltar back,
I'm not sure how we fix that,
but anybody in the European
Union who wants something
from Britain is now in
position to demand it.
So this is the most
awful negotiation
that you can imagine, and
the most sensible thing
to do would be to give
up the whole idea.
So I think that's probably
a good place to stop.
>> Thomas Bagger:
Can I have a --
just because Robert was kind
enough to bring up the case
of Dukfitz who saved the lives
of 7,000 Danish Jews 75 years
ago and it brought me back
to your question
about education.
The way I tell this story
of the last 30 years to me
and my own sort of illusions,
intellectual illusions
about grand convergence and
the end of history is also
to realize that in
reality the future is open
and that we should be aware
of the grand generalization.
So I'm very much with you
on sort of little steps
to make the world better,
but I like the Dukfitz' case
because I don't think he did
it because he was concerned
about a world dominated
by America in the future.
I think he did it because
he knew it was wrong
if it went ahead, he knew
what was coming and he decided
that he was in a position,
he knew the right people
to actually open a door for
these 7,000 people to escape
to Sweden across
the narrow waterway
between Denmark and Sweden.
And what that story
really tells in the midst
of very dark times is
individuals matter,
people matter, they
can change the world.
And I think that would
be the fallacy from sort
of saying farewell to the
grand generalization of 1989,
that the future is sort of
predetermined, only to turn
around and say, well,
we were too optimistic,
now the world belongs
to the strong man
or to the authoritarian system.
None of that is predetermined
either,
so it actually does matter
what you're interested in,
which position you're in, and
what you do with the space
that is accorded to you.
And I think that's actually
quite an optimistic outcome
for me.
So my, I would say be curious
and aspire to something.
>> Robert Cooper: And you never
know when you may get the chance
to make some decisive decision.
>> Thomas Bagger: We
all don't know, yes,
and that may be a test
but it also may be a way
to prove yourself and
actually make the world better.
>> Ivan Krastev: History does
not end, but the panels do.
And I want very much to thank
you, and I really do believe
that people matter, even
people on the panel matter.
So thank them.
Thank you very much and
thanks to The Kluge Center.